On 8 August 2008, the same day that the 2008
Beijing Olympic Games kicked off, the Russian
army launched its full-scale invasion of Georgia.
The most important event of the decade for
China, the Olympic Games that were to crown
the process of the full incorporation of the
communist country into the international community,
was to be marred by Vladimir Putin and his
warmongering aspirations.
At that time, Xi Jinping was not yet at the
helm of China.
Instead it was his predecessor, Hu Jintao,
who reacted discreetly, but was deeply irritated
with Moscow, because of the date chosen for
the invasion: the same day that the Olympic
flame would light up China for the first time.
It seems, VisualPolitik community, that although
much has happened since then, some habits
never change.
As if it were a kind of déjà vu, Putin made
the decision to invade Ukraine just at the
time when China was hosting another Olympic
Games, the Beijing 2022 Winter Games.
In fact, it is believed that Xi Jinping asked
the Russian leader to postpone his invasion
until after the closing of the games.
And whether or not this is true, the point
is that only four days after the closing of
these games, Putin's hordes were launched
on Ukraine.
Since then, the attitude of the People's Republic
of China has been tremendously ambiguous and
erratic.
But one thing has become very clear:
Xi Jinping is moving further and further away
from his predecessors.
During all this time, throughout a year of
war and despite the terrible crimes committed
by the Russian army, the Chinese dictator
has remained silent, on the sidelines...
At least, until now.
This image will surely take a long time to
be forgotten.
Yes, the image that some doubted would happen
and that others announced as inevitable finally
came to pass.
The dictators of China and Russia, Xi Jinping
and Vladimir Putin, together at a bilateral
summit in Moscow, just one year after the
start of the war.
It was not the first time they have met since
the beginning of the invasion, but it was
the first time they met at the highest level
and within the framework of a bilateral summit.
Perhaps for this reason, many have interpreted
Xi's visit to Moscow as an endorsement of
Putin, a way to legitimize the Russian leader
on the international scene and, perhaps, also
to whitewash his operations.
Even more so when the visit took place only
a few days after news stories like this one
broke.
(ICC judges issue arrest warrant for Vladimir
Putin over alleged war crimes – The Guardian)
However, this is only the footnote.
The truth is that Xi Jinping's visit to Russia
is about more than just handshakes or forced
smiles.
It was, above all, Beijing's latest attempt
to become the capital most antagonistic to
Washington once and for all.
The clear alternative to Western leadership.
Now, does all this mean that China will ultimately
side with Russia?
Is Beijing really as neutral as they claim
to be?
What on earth are the true Chinese intentions
with this apparent rapprochement with Putin?
Who has the upper hand in this whole story?
VisualPolitik viewers, in this video we are
going to answer these questions so keep watching
this video.
(THE 'MULTIPOLAR ORDER')
Take a look at this striking moment.
Here you see Wang Yi, head of the Chinese
Communist Party's Central Commission for Foreign
Affairs, Xi Jinping's top foreign policy advisor,
together with representatives of Saudi Arabia
and Iran.
Two countries that in theory hate each other
have now decided to re-establish diplomatic
relations.
And they have done so thanks to China's mediation.
It is not very common to see the Chinese as
mediators in international problems, but it
seems that now this is precisely the new path
that the Chinese regime wants to follow.
And the conflict between Russia and Ukraine
seems to be his next target.
At the end of February 2023, coinciding with
the first anniversary of the war, China presented
a twelve-point plan to, in theory, provide
a political solution to the conflict.
In reality this was something of a take-it-or-leave-it
plan.
They didn't even consult Ukraine's opinion
on the twelve points presented.
Nor are they very concise.
In fact, most of the points include extremely
general things like respecting the sovereignty
of all countries, ceasing hostilities and
reducing strategic risks.
The important thing is that with this document
China already had its peace plan.
Theoretically now the Chinese are going to
start working to see how these points can
be realized.
And that is surely what explains news items
like this in the Chinese media:
("European leaders' trips to China highlight
Beijing's role as a 'peace promoter'.
– Global Times)But, of course, the doubt,
the big question mark in this whole story
is...
Can we really consider China as a neutral
player between Russia and Ukraine capable
of acting as a mediating country in this conflict?
Well, what can I say?
Words like these don't help:
And I don't know about you, but, for Xi to
tell Putin that they are driving changes together,
doesn't seem like the best cover letter for
becoming a mediator.
However, just a moment, because to stop at
these images would be a terribly simple and
unfortunate analysis of this whole situation.
Beijing talks about its peace plan...
But what if China really doesn't care if the
war ends soon?
Yes, yes, you heard correctly.
That is the question.
Let me explain.
Initially, this war was a nuisance for China:
Suddenly everyone began to worry about national
security.
Western support for Ukraine overcame barriers
that could be considered a precedent for other
situations, like Taiwan, for instance.
The United States greatly improved its international
standing and had the luxury of restricting
the sale of advanced technology to China itself.
And to top it all off, the global economic
slowdown contributed to China's economic growth
in 2022 falling to almost half of the government's
target.
However, where there's a will, there's a way.
Take note because right now, we will identify
at least three main reasons why things may
not be seen by the Chinese regime the same
way as we think.
The first of these has to do with dough.
The extraordinary economic benefits China
is getting from Western sanctions on Russia.
Do you want a concrete example of all this?
Then take a look at this graph:
Of course, energy is the key driver of China's
imports.
The war, sanctions and European disengagement
from Russia have allowed China to buy record
amounts of gas and oil at deep discounts,
just when its economy is not at its best.
Russia needs to sell as much as it can, even
if that means selling much more cheaply.
And so, in the months of January and February
2023, with an increase of almost 24% year-on-year,
Russia unseated Saudi Arabia as China's largest
oil supplier.
Of course, Russia cannot flood China with
oil and gas, basically because a) it lacks
the infrastructure and b) unlike the Germans,
the Chinese have always been very wary of
their energy security.
At the beginning of 2023, Russia's share of
Chinese purchases was already above 20%.
So the margin seems small.
However, the idea now is to replace purchases
using ships with gas sent via pipelines.
We are talking, for instance, about trying
to speed up the deadlines for the construction
of Power Of Siberia 2, a new gas pipeline
that could transport, through more than 2,600
km, up to 50 billion cubic meters of gas,
which would double the current Russian gas
export capacity to China.
Of course, there is one problem: Chinese estimates
are to import 38 billion cubic meters of gas
by 2025, while the Russians aspire to be able
to sell them 98 bcm by 2030.
And with oil it is a very similar story.
Let's just say there is a massive divide between
what China wants to buy and what Russia wants
to sell.
So, for the Chinese to agree to further increase
their energy exposure to Russia, the Kremlin
will have to commit to much lower prices,
give guarantees and jump through the hoops
of whatever King Xi says.
Because don't forget one thing: this is not
a relationship between equals.
The "special relationship" between Russia
and China may end up making the former a kind
of vassal State of the latter.
And this is in fact the second great advantage
that the war could have for China: a much
greater political influence.
A new degree of influence that they themselves
have dubbed: the multipolar order.
The idea of the multipolar order is to bring
together the power spheres of Russia and China,
the Russophile and Sinophile world, to create
a new global power axis to serve as a counterweight
to the US in all fields.
The small detail is that now, with the enormous
weakening that Russia is suffering, China
could take advantage of that situation to
impose its geopolitical, economic and military
interests over any Russian demands.
Any examples of where this could go?
Well, one of the possible scenarios in which
China could use Russia to consolidate its
power would be in Africa.
But it is not only about the geostrategic
field when we talk about Chinese influence.
There is also the economic field.
Take a look.
(Putin told Xi Russia's ready to switch to
yuans in foreign trade – Yahoo News)
Basically, what this change would imply is
that Russia would stop trading in dollars
with countries in Asia, Latin America and
Africa, switching to the Renminbi, which is
the name of China's currency commonly known
as the yuan.
In fact, in 2022, the yuan's share of Russian
export payments increased from 0.5 percent
to 16 percent.
And, for example, in February 2023, the yuan
overtook the dollar for the first time in
history as the most traded currency on the
Moscow Stock Exchange, with almost 40 percent
of transactions.
It is what many have already called the Petroyuan...
Of course, its consequences have been greatly
exaggerated.
The yuan is not capable of replacing the dollar.
Why?
Basically because it lacks legal certainty
and because China maintains strict capital
controls.
But even so, this change could boost China's
influence in Russia and in general throughout
the entire Central Asian region.
Finally, there is the military issue.
Russia is suffering an enormous military attrition,
which along with the sanctions is having two
very clear consequences:
On the one hand, Russia's military capability
has been sapped, virtually leaving China as
the sole major military power in Central Asia.
On the other hand, when the war is over and
Russia needs to acquire new military equipment
to replace its losses, if the sanctions are
not lifted, they are likely to turn to the
Chinese military industry for hardware and
components.
And it’s not just Russia.
A good many of Russia's customers could gradually
shift to Chinese industry.
So there you have it, these would be the three
ways in which China could aspire to benefit
from all this mess.
Three core ideas with which Xi Jinping seems
to want to make up for the great blow that
the war has caused them.
And it is right here that we come to a big
dilemma.
Listen up.
(THE GREAT DILEMMA)
After what we have told you in this video,
if you had to answer the question we asked
you at the beginning about whether or not
China is really neutral in regards to Russia,
what answer would you give?
China does not have a neutral position, basically
because Xi Jinping has found a path in the
war to push his particular agenda of confrontation
with the West.
Also, don't forget that the Chinese economy
is starting to experience a lot of problems,
so there’s nothing better than having a
scapegoat on hand.
You know how it goes, no, we're not to blame
for the problems, it's because of the war.
However, this is not the whole story.
Right here we have arrived at the great dilemma
facing the Chinese government.
On the one hand, as we have seen, the war
may have benefits for Xi Jinping's new agenda,
but, on the other hand, it also involves many
problems that media outlets usually overlook:
For example, the war is causing its Asia-Pacific
neighbors to increase their military spending
and move even closer to the United States.
This may structurally weaken China's ambitions
to become the dominant power in the Asia-Pacific.
At the same time, it is also contributing
to the further deterioration of China's already
strained economic, trade and political relations
with the West.
Which is exactly what China does not need
at the moment.
Let's just say that the war has made many
governments perceive dictatorships like Putin's
and Xi Jinping's as untrustworthy.
To make matters worse, the war is also slowing
global economic growth, a growth that China
needs more than ever if it is to overcome
all the problems it faces: we are talking
about things like the bursting of the real
estate bubble, the technology crisis, banking
problems, hyper-indebtedness of local governments,
and so on and so forth.
And, of course, if they fail to overcome all
these imbalances, the new multipolar world
order of which they dream so much could be
a very short-lived one.
It seems that Xi Jinping has dramatically
turned the rudder with respect to his predecessors...
And the results have not been particularly
good.
Now this seems to be their latest gamble,
to try to cash in on the war Russia has provoked
in Ukraine.
Of course, it is not clear that China can
really derive any benefit from this game.
What is clear is that it is neither a neutral
country nor a reliable regime.
But for now the questions are over to you:
Do you think China will manage to benefit
from the current situation?
Will Russia end up becoming a kind of vassal
State of Beijing?
What future do you predict for the alliance
between China and Russia?
Will they really be able to promote a new
world order?
Leave us your thoughts below and if you found
this video interesting don't forget to like
it and subscribe to VisualPolitik and Patreon
to keep up to date with all our content.
Thank you very much for watching.
All the best and see you next time.